ah the sun
so bright
so
hot
time to jump into your super heat
resistant spaceship
and get so close you could touch it if
you dare
[Music]
how would you get to the sun's surface
what kind of temperatures would you
encounter
and what kind of materials could even
protect you from this scorching heat
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you touched the sun
the sun is so massive that it accounts
for 99.8
of our solar system's total mass
with a diameter of 1.4 million
kilometers
you could fit about 1 million earths
inside of it
it burns bright due to the process of
nuclear fusion
hydrogen atoms fuse to create helium and
it's worked that way for four and a half
billion years
it'll be another five billion years
before it burns through all of its
hydrogen
then it will burn helium and will start
to swell
eventually it will swallow mercury venus
and the earth
so you better touch it before it touches
you
okay it's time to head off on your
journey to the sun
considering that big ball of gas has
such a massive gravitational pull
it should be a pretty easy flight
right
well this journey is going to be more of
an odyssey
that's because earth is traveling almost
entirely sideways relative to the sun
at a speed of about 108 000 kilometers
per hour
to get to the sun you'd need to cancel
out that sideways motion
and that would require a lot of energy
about 55 times more energy than it takes
to travel to mars
like the parker solar probe your uber
ship is capable of speeds reaching
163 kilometers per second
but you're still going to have plenty of
time to prepare on the way
after three years you'd arrive at the
sun's outermost layer
the corona
this layer is located 7 to 10 million
kilometers above the sun's surface
and big surprise it's hot
about 1 million degrees celsius
and that's about 900 times hotter than
lava
at this point you'd also be exposed to
massive amounts of radiation
make sure you slather on copious amounts
of specially formulated sunscreen that
could shield you from everything from
ultraviolet light to gamma rays
without this you could get radiation
sickness leading to cancer then death
and not the most ideal kind of
sunbathing right
obviously you should wear sunglasses too
or better yet have a sunshield in your
heat resistant space suit the sun would
be tens of thousands of times brighter
here than it was back on earth
traveling onward you'd reach the
chromosphere
now you're three thousand kilometers
above the sun's surface and surprisingly
temperatures here would take a big drop
in the chromosphere they'd range from 3
700 to 7 700 degrees
celsius and unlike other layers it would
get cooler as you get closer to the sun
but look out
massive loops of plasma could jet out
toward you
these are solar prominences and they are
extremely hot
plus they could be ten times the
diameter of earth
you now see how granulated the surface
of the sun looks up close
below you would be bright expanses as
wide as texas surrounded by narrow
darker regions
next stop the photosphere
you'd have finally arrived at the
surface of the sun
as much as you'd like to land here
you couldn't
that's because the sun
has no actual surface
it would be like stepping out onto a
cloud
a scorching searing cloud
the gravity would be so intense that if
you weighed 70 kilograms back on earth
you'd now weigh a whopping
1800 kilograms
outside of your ship
that extra weight would crush your bones
and organs
okay pushing deeper from here you'd
enter the convective zone
temperatures would now hit 2 million
degrees celsius
that would be almost 400 times hotter
than earth's core
the density here would be so intense
even light would have a hard time
escaping
a little bit like in a black hole
you'd be cooking in a soup of densely
packed solar particles blinded by their
luminosity
finally you'd make it to the core
half a million kilometers below the
surface
this is where the sun's nuclear fusion
occurs
okay so what would happen now if you
reached out and tried to touch the sun
this would be light years beyond
sizzling
you'd be almost instantly obliterated
a cremation furnace has temperatures of
1000 degrees celsius
that wouldn't even compare to the
millions of degrees you'd encounter down
here
and sorry to say
there's no material on earth that could
withstand these temperatures long enough
for you to find out what the sun really
feels like
the closest we could get right now is
about 1.6 million kilometers away
probably should have mentioned that at
the start
now you could stick around and wait to
find out when the sun swallows the earth
but
that's a story
for another what if
[Music]